jorge freire haiti é fredes estilo
kitsch noite 4 sustos prega a área uma
promessa eu vou passar a noite o quadro
hoje todos duvidavam
eu sempre acreditou em si daqui freire
viu no cio
veja só eu sei o que eu passei
você não acredito você sai você
finalmente eu vou acabar o vídeo está já
concluído
além da terra a sua produtiva aqui hoje
que quatro foco em horas a passar meu 4
não seis foram as outras duas vítimas
garapu qual meu deus
alegria lá fui girar e 4 pessoal muito
tempo
o pessoal está no singular
vamos ver vamos ver olha não queria o
elevador é pessoal à noite 55 finalmente
ram 1.105 ser um grande estava muito
tempo aqui o meu já estava super
estressado e consegui passar final
aumentando a plant tcheca um valor x 1
no estande blu ray ou é um choque
vamos lá agir com cuidado é por onde é
por um time forte né é que
foi meio estranho mas para lá vai outro
registo
outro vídeo fosse onde fosse
eu não preciso ainda estar e sentir
sentir o cheiro a favor é o não fosse o
telefone de onde a cirurgia foi ótima
stable e velho rock'n'roll time neste
ano outra idéia que eu tenho que fazer
oque eu tenho que fazer que é uma coisa
é o que conta uma história tão bonita e
quer tentar né e incondicional do mal
dentro de mim e não consegui arranjar
vaga que o resto amiga do fixo
ame receio para escanteio eu justo agora
que sou eu juro baixo
vamos lá está aqui no mesmo quarto que
nós aqui dentro está calmo
rosinha que qualquer falha a bola quica
pessoal ao código 81 foi ficando a gente
tem muita pressão muita fé no cérebro
[ __ ] foi aquilo fui muito por um
certo meu x tempo e opção é muito pré
chennai do ano sobretudo ela convivia lo
e igreja
[ __ ] foi por pouco foi por pouco foi
muito pouco vamos lá pessoal vamos lá
vamos nós conseguimos atender a outra
vez ela volta bem atrás no tempo
eu acho que não acontece nada por não
acreditar no fox aparece após porque o
caso está ativado não é
eu acho que eu tô tranquila depois que
não há pressa pois claro que importa
história na can então então dar crédito
precisa história atenção pois claro
então sim mas agora eu vou só clicar no
botão de otto bittencourt um sorvete
só não funciona eu tenho que ouvir tudo
outra vez
o técnico andré possa cantar o hino
então não não funciona já fosse assim
ok vamos lá ocorre sol acolhe quinto
to ai mãe foi for fire with fire one one
one one foi a única coisa que eu vejo
que proceda com o cartão é isto o que
ela quer mim é o botãozinho outra vez
ora isto foi assim que eu tenho até
testou e testarem quem tinha de pedir
para um dia né
o hiv está muito bom ou muito bom início
é um pouco deste jogo mas meu estilo
a brutal tá muito bom não tem que ir
embora agora beckham se irá agora vai
iniciar agora um susto
ai meu coração meu eu voltei e vou
morrer aqui ok vamos lá tentar outra vez
agora vou ter muito cuidado
tá aí qual foi agora é na hora
que casal é 22 está por aí incluído o
foco foi outra vez
porém oito medo de mexer eu tenho que
proteger história exatamente na possui
no cunene
é todo estiveram aqui hoje também teve
aqui todos tiveram que presidente está
no momento só passou a acreditar pessoa
ae uma toma uma turma
eu não digo eu não digo deus
não acredito
o seu fim
é o fim
que isto
a isso eu e os painéis supostamente joel
o que hoje geram a que originou aqui os
fãs
fred sister location o legal voltar no
jogo pessoal curso que passar o jogo
diga que é muito tempo e passar isso meu
brutal
lindo lindo é duro jogo sol durei mel
digo mãe quem quer uma que o sódio é que
o aeroporto ganhou por paulão carvalho
sei lá eu não saí eu não estou muito por
dentro da história mas eu sei que estive
na série friends sister location cá
muito ligado e conectado a história
portanto avião aí nos comentários
assim um zoom do que é que isto foi
porque não se conhece muito bem a
história não é porque eu não tive assim
tão atento e não aceitam o promotor como
você estava não é portanto explica emae
porque é que a pessoa que quem era o que
os olhos
para conseguir passar o jogo é do e fui
embora deixem ver se isto tem mais noite
já estão assim porque não é o momento
jogos têm sempre a minha câmera com a
sima treinam há um câmera óculos filme
de uma estrela pessoal é preciso que
estrela e tem extras né a aac de
eletrônicos tenha playb eu chamo sempre
esta linha tronic de sistemas não ela
chama-se banheiro então é isso né mas
tem santo ver brutal
isto é como é o são paulo dentro né
se o muito ó são a cabo em si é o que
dora gallery estão mapa
a oca é basicamente que neste gesto de
paz e encontra um tipo de doenças
relacionadas ao jogo como as modulações
um mapa e taylor aí aquelas ruas baratas
né e duas pratas que ficam lá tentaram
pegar quatro horas
o crime só vocês saberem quem é este
personagem e como se deslocar e esse
personagem digam aí nos comentários que
eu tenho que fazê lo
eu não saí supostamente estava a
bloquear né de urina mas para então
chegar aqui pessoal espero que vocês
tenham gostado deste fascinante é fredes
strokes já sabem não esqueça de deixar
em estíria história tudo que eu queria
saber sobre a estagnação é fredes e
muito obrigado por não terem acompanhado
até aqui já sabem quanto eu posso falar
é que favorito fiquem vai até a próxima
semana